hi this is kim from khan academy and
today i'm learning about the tenth
amendment to the constitution the last
amendment in the bill of rights the bill
of rights was added in order to calm
some of the fears held by those who felt
that the new stronger central government
under the constitution might infringe
upon the powers of the states or on
individual liberties the tenth amendment
was specifically designed to allay those
fears it reads the power is not
delegated to the united states by the
constitution nor prohibited by it to the
states are reserved to the states
respectively or to the people so what
does this actually mean to learn more i
sought out the help of some experts
randy barnett is the carmack waterhouse
professor of legal theory at the
georgetown university law center and
director of the georgetown center for
the constitution robert shapiro is the
asa griggs candler professor of law and
dean of emory law school so professor
barnett can you tell us a little bit
just about what that means it's a little
dense during the ratification debates
there was
lots of opposition to the constitution
in fact the constitution uh only was
ratified after the proponents of the
constitution who called themselves
federalists
promised that amendments would be made
to the constitution because it was the
lack of a bill of rights
and other changes that cause people to
oppose it and so they they said they
would put a bill of rights on afterwards
and at that point in in these
ratification
conventions conventions started
proposing amendments to congress that
accompanied their ratification so they
ratified it they said but here are some
changes we want to see made and one of
the changes that several states asked
for
was wording that was very much like what
became the tenth amendment a
reaffirmation of the fact that the
federal government was going to be one
of limited and enumerated powers
and the 10th amendment is an expression
of the idea that while there are more
powers given to the central government
of the united states
it's still the case that the only power
that the central government the national
government can exercise
are powers specifically given to it by
the constitution
so the tenth amendment is an embodiment
of the structural principle that the
only powers that the national government
has are those that are delegated to it
in the constitution as opposed to the
states
who have general powers within their
boundaries one of the things that i
think we see in the bill of rights
is many
examples of the framers
responding to particular historical
evils that they had witnessed in england
or in europe more generally so was there
something in particular they had in mind
they're trying to prevent with the tenth
amendment i think the particular evil
they were concerned with was the concern
of a
distant powerful centralized government
that had been the government of king
george they wanted to make sure that
wasn't the government of president
george washington and the tenth
amendment states that the national
government is not an all-powerful body
with general authority to do whatever it
wants it's in line with the structure of
the constitution which says there are
certain powers given to the national
government there certainly are definite
powers given to them but only some
powers
and that idea of being concerned of a
distant strong government far away from
the people is really what underlies the
principle of the constitution and that's
what we see in the 10th amendment
specifying that the powers not delegated
to the united states by the constitution
are reserved to the states
so what would you say is important about
the 10th amendment it reaffirms that the
basic structure of the constitution is
one of limited and enumerated powers
how limited of course is a matter of
debate but the fact that they are
limited and that all other powers are
reserved to the states respectively or
to the people is now a matter of
constitutional law it's a matter of the
text
the other thing that's interesting about
the tenth amendment is that uh in
congress they added the phrase or to the
people at the end the states did not
propose that language the states
proposed the wording of the 10th
amendment and it just would have stopped
where it said are reserved to the states
and so that made the ninth amendment
less a state's rights provision than the
states had wanted and less a state's
rights provision than people read it
today so the people have rights in fact
nowhere in the constitution does it say
anyone except individuals or persons
have rights it doesn't say states have
rights the tenth amendment is about
reserve powers and those are the powers
that the people have to govern
themselves as well as other powers and
what this shows is that the people not
only have rights they also have powers
perhaps the most important thing however
is to note that these two are separate
provisions that the supreme court has
sometimes read the tenth amendment or
the ninth amendment as meaning basically
the tenth amendment that the people have
reserved powers but we know they're
different because they are put in there
separately and in fact madison placed a
much higher premium on the importance of
the ninth amendment as opposed to the
tenth the tenth amendment and the ninth
amendment really speak to the the
structure of the constitutional system
what it means to have a constitution
setting up a national government said
the tenth amendment is really a
statement of the overall structure of
what we call federalism certain powers
given to the national government and
then powers reserved to the states the
ninth amendment speaks more to the
rights side of things that is we have
certain rights which are set forth in
the bill of rights the first amendment
about freedom of speech and religion the
fourth amendment about protection
against unreasonable searches and
seizures
and there was some concern expressed in
the late 1700s
that if you specified those rights did
that somehow mean that the national
government could do whatever else it
wanted
and so the ninth amendment says the
enumeration of certain rights shall not
be construed to deny or disparage others
retained by the people so it's in line
with the idea that the national
government has certain powers but they
are limited because other powers are
reserved to the states
and the power of the national government
may also be limited because there are
rights that are reserved to the people
how do you think the 10th amendment
tells us that the framers intended the
federal government and the state
governments to relate to each other
the tenth amendment really is a little
more about structure than about specific
content so i think the tenth amendment
embodies the idea that we should think
carefully about what are the powers
given to the national government
understanding that whatever is given to
the national government may
take powers away from the states and so
the 10th amendment is really a
text that embodies the overall principle
of federalism that is implicit
throughout the united states
constitution
in fact the tenth amendment is in some
respects kind of a replay of the first
sentence of article one that says that
congress only has the powers here and
granted states have the powers by
contrast the 10th amendment affirms that
states have the powers that
are not granted to the federal
government but are granted to them under
state constitutions so just as the
federal government has the powers it has
under the us constitution state
governments have the powers they have
under state constitutions and the people
reserve all other powers to themselves
so how has the 10th amendment been
interpreted by the supreme court over
time i imagine there have been some
cases about this as the federal
government has gotten more powerful
exactly so the tenth amendment which
really is just about the structure of
government saying some power is given to
the national government and there's a
concern about the power reserve to the
states the understanding of that has
really evolved with the understanding of
the breadth of the power of the national
government
and what we've seen over the course of
history in the united states is that
there's been a broader understanding of
the power of the government of the
united states that expansion has really
come mainly in two forms uh one is with
regard to the government's power to
regulate interstate commerce
and the broad interpretation of the
national government's power to regulate
commerce we saw that particularly
in the context of the great depression
when there is viewed to be tremendous
social dislocation
tremendous economic problems in the
united states
to the point at which some feared that
the american democracy might collapse
and the national government then
was allowed to exercise more authority
over the economy the the supreme court
in the new deal declared the tenth
amendment a truism meaning as long as
you find a power
then you can't have a tenth amendment
objection to that power
that's right as a logical matter except
that if you continue to expand
your interpretation of those powers then
you are basically violating the spirit
if not the letter of the tenth amendment
and finally then during the rehnquist
court uh until today the supreme court
started using the 10th amendment to
enforce the spirit of the constitution
which preserved the existence of states
even when congress was claiming powers
that went far beyond those that were
originally
mentioned in the constitution's text so
in some cases in the early 20th century
you did see the united states supreme
court
interpreting the 10th amendment to limit
to some extent what the national
government could do if say the issue
were
child labor or minimum wage laws things
like that the question is is that really
something that the national government
can do
but
in the wake of we say the the
new deal
legislation that was put forward by
congress in the great depression of the
1930s and approved by the supreme court
we've seen the supreme court take
a much narrower understanding of the
10th amendment or again we can really
see the 10th amendment in balance with
the power of the national government and
as we've understood a broader role for
the national government
the
role reserved to the states has shrunk
this is fascinating so one thing that
interests me about this in terms of u.s
history is the way that later on the
14th amendment is interpreted to
incorporate the bill of rights into the
states so how does the 14th amendment's
protection of equal citizenship rights
then intersect with the idea that states
have certain individual powers so
certainly in the wake of the civil war
we saw the 13th 14th and 15th amendments
the 13th amendment banning slavery the
14th amendment guaranteeing rights of
national citizenship and
equal protection and due process and the
15th amendment guaranteeing the right to
vote all of which expanded the power of
the national government and particularly
the 14th amendment and its guarantee of
equal protection of laws and due process
of laws were really new
national restrictions on state authority
a new empowerment of the national
government to protect individuals no
matter what state they were so
since the structure of the 10th
amendment is not about protecting a
particular body of power it would be
natural that as the 14th amendment
expands the role of the national
government that there would be
less for the states to do completely
immune from federal intrusion the 14th
amendment represents a fundamental
change
to our system of federalism precisely
because
it has a section 5 in the 14th amendment
which empowers congress to enforce the
provisions of the previous four sections
including section 1 which has the
citizenship clause and the privileges or
immunities clause and the due process
clause and equal protection clause so
congress is given an enumerated power
to protect individuals from their own
state governments violating their
fundamental rights under those section 1
provisions that's a change in our
federalism that is a consistent with the
10th amendment because it's a it's a
power that is delegated to congress by
the constitution by section 5 of the
14th amendment what happened to that
however immediately after it was enacted
as the supreme court decided and i think
quite consciously in their minds decided
that this change in our system of
federalism was objectionable in fact it
was the product of radical republicans
in congress and it really needed to be
undone and so in one of the earliest
examples of what i would call living
constitutionalism a series of cases was
in a series of cases the supreme court
cut back
on the powers of congress to protect
individuals from the rights of their
citizens in cases like the
slaughterhouse cases or united states
versus crookshank uh or uh plessy versus
ferguson these are cases of the civil
rights cases or more in which the
supreme court actually cut back on the
scope in order to restore the federalism
that existed prior to the civil war that
the justices preferred i think based on
its text and its interpretation over
time we see the 10th amendment really
being a recognition of the federalist
structure of the united states
constitution meaning there will be a
national government and there will be
states
and that has not changed over time what
has changed over time is an
understanding about the scope of the
role of the national government how much
power the national government needs
either to regulate the national economy
or to protect individual rights
certainly the interpretation of the
interstate commerce clause and the
enactment of the 14th amendment have
been key elements in expanding the role
of national power but all of this
expansion of national power is
completely consistent with the language
of the 10th amendment which again does
not specify any particular
kind of power reserved to the states
it just recognizes that there will be a
national government and there will be
states so how have the courts been
utilizing the 10th amendment in recent
years in recent years the courts have
been using this 10th amendment not so
much for what it says but for the s its
spirit the idea that it reaffirms the
importance of states in our
constitutional structure what's happened
since the new deal is the powers of
congress under its enumerated powers
have been so broadly or expansively
interpreted that if they were all to be
applied to states the way they are
applied to private individuals and
private companies essentially congress
could basically run all the states using
its commerce power
combined with its necessary and proper
clause power etc um what this what the
supreme court has done in recent years
it says this violates the first
principles
of our constitutional order which says
states are important the ninth the tenth
amendment affirms that uh and therefore
they've created certain carve out or
special protections from states for
states from these broadly or expansively
read congressional powers none of this
is really stemming from the original
meaning of the tenth amendment because
what's already happened is the original
meaning of the enumerated powers has
already been exceeded but what it's
attempting to do is to keep in place the
balance between federal and state powers
that the tenth amendment represented
but doing so in a way that's basically
modern it's adding the states to a list
of protected entities uh protected from
expansive federal power so we've learned
that the tenth amendment reaffirms that
the federal government of the united
states will be a limited government with
enumerated powers but as the scope of
the federal government has grown
so has debate over the interpretation of
the tenth amendment which actions of the
states can the federal government
regulate and which exceed federal power
to learn more about the 10th amendment
visit the national constitution center's
interactive constitution and khan
academy's resources on u.s government
and politics